hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play robot vacuum
simulator 2013 now as many of you know I
am a huge fan of robot vacuum cleaning
simulators I've been a fan since robot
vacuum cleaning simulator 2012 and I'm
really hoping that this one lives up to
my expectations because the previous one
set the bar pretty darn high in terms of
quality so I'm gonna give this a go but
I don't know this is incredible
a little stuttering the baguette oh
there goes okay wow I never in my
wildest dreams could I have imagined
that such such a such a visceral
experience could come from a video game
this is absolutely mind-blowing I I'm at
a loss for words this is absolutely
incredible I don't know what to say I'm
taking aback because the previous
version if you played it before was in
2d and this one feels so lifelike oh my
godness just look at the detail the
apartment of this rug it's absolutely
incredible and the music Hey look the
music speaks to me deep in my soul I've
never had a gaming experience like this
before it I mean The Last of Us just
can't compare I'm I'm just oh now I get
the jazzy feel into it
alright okay a man the mood changes in
this game
absolutely astonishing I feel I feel
uplifted from RE whenever all right
enough digging around this is robot
vacuum cleaning simulator it is the most
visceral and gritty experience in terms
of household cleaning that you could
possibly imagine
ah probably like many of you as a child
I wished that I could get on the floor
and gobble up little gray balls not
weird in any way I don't know what your
childhood was like but that's what I
wanted to do guess we all wanted to be
our own version of pac-man on the floor
and here we are even though they didn't
have robot vacuum cleaners when I was a
kid that's all I'm gonna say about that
right now so the objective of this game
is obviously to make sure that this
apartment is [ __ ] and span as possible
make sure they're not even a little bit
of dust and dirt is left for anyone to
trip on and also this game comes with a
multiplayer mode which is really really
integral to the experience I believe cuz
I mean you can get the peaceful cleaning
experience that everyone desires like by
yourself it's like this is like playing
The Sims and having just your sim being
made and just go into other people's
houses and cleans that's what this is
like for those of you and I know you're
out there that enjoy that kind of
experience because I do I know I do
that's what it's all about I mean this
is what it's all about right here ladies
and gentlemen this is what gaming has
been building towards throughout the
entire history of gaming and I just
watched a baby about the first gaming
console ever and I know I know when the
guy was designing that first gaming
console that didn't even have graphics
on the TV that hold it overlays on it
the Odyssey they were really thinking
boy if I could get the monotony of
everyday life and somehow automate it
and then take that automation and
somehow put it in a video game and then
uh nota mate it that is the golden dream
right there that is the Holy Grail video
gaming and ladies and gentlemen it is
fun we have in today we are at the
pinnacle of gaming evolution right here
forget your half-life forget your any
other sort of great games Last of Us
doesn't even compare you know I don't
care how good beyond 2 souls is this is
where it's at
everyone wants to be I can't wait for
12v 1200 watt vacuum cleaning simulator
matches because that would be something
to see and I have a feeling I'm actually
approaching the end all too soon
I don't want this experience to end Oh
No
how am I gonna get into under the chair
chair excuse me pardon me uh uh uh uh uh
okay all right enough of victory I'm not
done yet
I can't start celebrating nice placement
on the refrigerator I can see that a lot
of planning went into this kitchen I
love the music the music just brings
everything together I've said that in
horror games you know you oh no I don't
know if I'm gonna fit through that gap
that gap I don't know if I'm gonna fit
through that gap dude okay I'm
celebrating a bit too much I'm just so
excited that's a fact that I'm able to
clean an apartment or a house I don't
even know what it is you know what I
find myself I don't care what it is
because what matters this is true
experience I mean I don't care if
there's no shadows if all the textures
are flat that's not important
graphics don't make a great game what
makes a great game is a great game play
and this ladies and gentlemen is
everything that I could possibly imagine
I think I've only got the bathroom of
the bedroom oh I'm glad I left the
bedroom for last because you all know
how dirty the bedroom can get I'll take
two children that's not what I meant but
a man was getting on the floor and
gobbling up gray balls no no no what I
meant no shut up everybody
don't mix all my words what I'm trying
to say is that the bedroom can be the
dirtiest place in the house sorry sorry
sorry sorry almost hit that toilet there
oh no I'm automatic this clearance
I don't think Oh oh by the skin of my
top of my robot knees whatever the hell
that is and I don't know why there'd be
dust in the more great Oh it's hair ah
oh I just gobbled up some hair it's
gonna get clogged Oh No I need just jam
space to unclog my brushes so that the
hair doesn't you know
you know probably a lot of you don't
know because a lot of you don't vacuum
regularly and you need to vacuum your
house regularly the cleared of dust and
allergens it's very important to live
hygienic ly oh no this is it
I've been costing uneasy mode for now oh
there's gotta take wait a minute now
this seems this seems almost too easy
oh wait a minute something's being
hidden from me where's the boss
the giant ball that I need to gobble up
the most I just need to stretch my jaw a
little I mean go attack it a little
harder I mean that doubled event don't
make so many words I need to go grab the
little the big ball and yank it around a
bit until it comes loose and I remember
I stopped talking for a moment everyone
just pay attention to music
okay enough with me the music break is
over I think this is the last ball that
I need to gobble that's the end I can't
believe the most life-changing game I've
ever played in my life is over
Thank You Sebastian row it makes it for
everything that you've done
Henrik Michele kenderson you made my
life better thank you for everyone who
has stuck with me through this let's
play till the end I know it's been a
long journey and I know that we've done
a lot in this time here and I'm really
sorry that it's over but hopefully next
year there will be a new installment or
all play the stupid duel mode with
someone I know whatever you want
I'd love to play more lose Henrik lilyc
hog was that the boss was that the boss
ball that I gobbled up just like any
other I don't even know anymore
thank you body in the buckets for being
such a great musical person and
Sebastian rode Banks's allmusic's burn
by Katherine Kieran aside Olli
gourville Kieran Olaf andreas a beer
girl loves her rocker Sebastian Roth
mazes kylajo bar mobile Sebastian you
just didn't feel its heart go anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
forget a taste for videos that I've done
and as oh I will see you the next with
you mama hi
you
son of a monkey my god bear